oh je was katy sr marx und herzlich
willkommen zur nächsten folge minecraft
nero wir sind ja in der letzten folge
gestorben was für eine überraschung sind
wir das schon jemals ich glaube nicht
und jetzt geht es wieder zurück in die
stadt zu gehen
patrick hat mich zum glück wieder belebt
hat er mir geschrieben und
dementsprechend hoffe ich jetzt einfach
mal dass wir ja ohne größere probleme
erstmal ganz einfach zum portal kommen
das ist ja immer so eine kleine qual
hier am spawnen dass man einfach zum
portal kommt überhaupt erstmal und dann
hoffe ich dass wir relativ schnell
wieder uns einfach aufbauen also dass
wir die sachen wieder finden
ich weiß nicht ob mir die sachen auch
gesichert hat aber ich hatte ihm gesagt
gab herstellt die vielleicht einfach
eine kiste dort wo ich gestorben bin ich
hoffe mal dass er das getan hat okay
leute wir machen richtige parcours muss
einfach weil gott ist mein pc es auch
schon wieder total abstrakt
hier können wir gern mal die kommentare
schreiben falls ihr stimmen auskennt was
ist es ist wurde am effektivsten
upzugraden
also eine neue grafikkarte rhein zu tun
oder ist halt ich glaube minecraft ist
immer total prozessor intensiv mein ich
zumindest erzählen ich kann mich aber
auch nicht so gut aus komme ich jetzt
überhaupt runter hey leute ich wollte
einfach die ganzen mob so ein bisschen
umgehen also das würde ich auf jeden
fall überleben
ja gut rande wahr die lakeside stressig
ok dann kamen wir erst mal ab abrisshaus
und hoffen dass wir nicht vor diesen
risiken bäumen wieder gejagt werden und
ich habe es nicht ganz genau auf die
zeit geschaut aber ab nach stadtgrün war
okay okay okay
tagsüber ist es nicht wieder so wenige
monster dass wieder so viele monster da
sind bei sonst geh ich mir erstmal paar
melonen wiederholen
das wäre auf jeden fall weil dann muss
ich nicht die ganze zeit ohne essen
rumlaufen und das sieht hier relativ
leer aus leute das ist doch schon mal
was
vorgeführt und cabrio das ist manchmal
voll gefährlich vor allen dingen im
neckar gibt es diesen effekt auch und
ist einfach im nervenkrieg season torres
effekt nein das ist dieser über das ist
dieser über boss was habe ich eigentlich
ein pech das ist dieser kost ja der ist
so gefährlich
warum haben wir so viele von denen
erwarte man gibt es noch es gibt glaube
ich noch von diesem haus zwischen gibt
es noch mal so einen richtigen endboss
der dann besonders gefährlich ist noch
mal machen oder es macht ja gar kein
spaß hier
okay leute es ist immer so ein richtiges
survival hier aber ich habe habe etwas
gehört hier die letzten tage was mich ja
wie soll ich sagen sehr beunruhigt hat
ich habe gehört dass ich zwei städte
zusammenschließen wollen um uns der
einzig wahren mächtigen stadtgrün
probleme zu machen
ich hoffe natürlich für die anderen
städte und auch für unsere sicherheit
dass das nur ein spaß ist weil ich habe
angst dass hier gleich so ein
kripobeamter feldbach ist das stressig
ich muss aber doch was essen würde
ok kann als ich werde ja auch nicht alle
abbauen und dann einfach nicht wieder
anpflanzen
ich hatte ja schon letztes mal mir
vorgenommen gehabt dass ich hier direkt
ein paar melonen anpflanzen gehe hoffe
ich komme ich jetzt einfach schnell
wieder raus auf der anderen seite und
dieser horst hat sich nicht darum
irgendwie bewegt
es gibt viele personen klimapaket das
habe ich erst mal geschafft es gibt auf
jeden fall irgendein kriegbaum ob also
der hat nämlich aussieht im krieg der
das übel stark ist also der tötet ein
sogar wenn du irgendwie einfach nur in
die nähe kommst worden hielt egal wie du
ausgerüstet ist
das ist ziemlich schrecklich und ich
hoffe einfach sehr dass ich nicht
kontakt machen werde mit diesem
unangenehmen zeitgenossen
so hat die renner listen ist relativ das
sorgt dafür dass das hier alles nicht so
wunderschön aussieht gibt es auch noch
dimension portal ich war noch nie in
irgendeiner dimension
aber ich glaube das geht ja auch schon
zu genüge bei anderen die da vorne wenig
das letzte folge gestorben
ich hoffe mal dass meine sachen
irgendwie noch da sind aber ich
befürchte fast dass die response sind
ich bin in diesem loch da gestorben was
ich mir gebuddelt habe so hoch da das
war wieder für monster da kein grabstein
ist noch da hey ich hab es wird
irgendwie meinen mit gomez verwechselt
oder so nicht das komme dann jetzt eine
voll geöffnet und das eigentlich ich
verstehe es nicht packt ihn jetzt
einfach mal auf dem friedhof und wie alt
man ist dann passt das schon alles so
fakt mein zeug ist die supporters hatte
ich jetzt hatte ich irgendwie nicht
erwartet ich dachte das pad das
vielleicht sichern könnte
aber mir gut keine vorbild waren ihn
vielmehr an mich dafür dass ich ständig
sterbe und jetzt musste ich mich muss
ich mich schon wieder bei patrick
bedient wird ja auch wieder nacht jetzt
und er will es ja wie hier wohl jeder
weiß deutlich gefährlicher wieder
trainieren
okay das war hat es zu seinem set
montiert wieder einen eisenring roman
the pet soviel gut bei mir einfach dafür
dass mir immer alles wurde
ich sage ich natürlich bescheid also
falls er damit ein problem hat wenn
welche - als wieder zurückgeben was ich
mir die ganze zeit hole und kann alles
schlecht fühle ich mich sowieso dabei
eigentlich müsste ich jetzt wirklich mal
meinen gehen also weit testplattform
aufgedrückt bekommen glaube ich
ich müsste wirklich mal mein gehen aber
ich musste mich auch um die ersten
versorgung kümmern
ich muss ich anschauen gehen ob komme
mir vielleicht sogar schon die gas
trainer vorbeigebracht hatte es wäre
natürlich der wahnsinn aber ein problem
ist auch dass ich auf jeden fall in den
nächsten tagen ein bisschen
vorproduzieren muss weil ich da nicht
die ganze zeit zu hause sein werde
deshalb wird es mich halt voll freuen
habe ich das rad umsonst geklaut
irgendjemand hat menschlich geschenk
gemacht und es hat perfekt okay das hat
mich irgendwie besonderen set bonus oder
so wie kann man das noch mal machen mit
der der heydt die haltbarkeit anschauen
weiß ich nicht genau aber ich glaube das
hängt jetzt nicht so super lange aber
trotzdem voll cool
mein plan ist aber auch noch hier okay
dann muss ich mir schon wieder dieses
sacrifice machen und muss auch ein
bisschen was mache ich denn jetzt ja ich
muss ein bisschen bisschen farben gehen
einfach mal diese folge so leid es mir
tut ich mag das gar nicht so gerne wenn
ich irgendwie folgen farben und
verschwende aber ja
11 oder steak rieping achters wann waren
tagsüber event einfach dass er das wäre
irgendwie was anderes gewesen so hier
maximal mein fuß hand alle besser
eigentlich auch nicht immer alle zulegen
aber andererseits hat vor gefährlich
zudem trete die gestern nur rum ohne
irgendwas zu machen
ich musste mir auch mal mit pc's machen
auf jeden fall
noch kurz vorher bitte des tages das
heißt ich sollte diese nach definitiv
drin verbringen und vielleicht irgendwas
am haus bauen wo man diese natura
viecher nerven halten das finde ich wenn
die um einen herum sind die ganze zeit
kann einen kleinen anbau hier mal machen
dann brauche ich einfach aus meiner
eigenen wand ein bisschen holz ab damit
der mit ines tricks machen kann und so
ich weiß nicht ob die häuser geschlossen
sein müssen dass man in der nacht safe
ist aber wir haben jetzt wieder was für
vernünftiges mit dem mit der rüstung von
patrick wohnen sport ist so ziemlich
meine einzige rettung in dem innen
ganzen game da ist können wir sogar mal
mit selbst erfahrenen materialien ein
richtig cooles schwert bereich sind das
die kinder aus schaut manchmal emma
stone sword sie von leistung so dass
auch so gut wie jahre habe ich letztens
schon festgestellt
ok also ein bisschen leid es mir
wirklich dass ich patrick die gast hat
alles klar essensversorgung steht heute
wirklich an
ich glaube ich mache das unten am fluss
einfach dass ich hier die ganzen sachen
anbau so und damit eins klar ich bin ich
vielleicht nur ein talent so sei es
vernünftig ok hiding fungi wer die
viecher sind hier ein bisschen ein
bisschen dangerous wie wir wissen
da könnte ich eigentlich so ein balkon
irgendwie hin machen ich den baum ab nee
eigentlich ist das ganz cool mit den
blättern hier
das mache ich ganz gern dass die hier
sind vielleicht einfach noch ein layer
drüber
so kann ich jetzt aber runter gehen kann
ich das riskieren dass die frage weil es
diesmal bin ich also gestorben
aber wir haben schon gemerkt die sachen
direkt wieder zurück bekomme ich hoffe
mal dass ich auch nicht zu übersehen
habe irgendwie mal im inventar was
wichtig gewesen wäre
was macht man eigentlich machen
eigentlich nicht sicher eine einheit zu
machen ist eigentlich eher
ungeschriebenes gesetz dass man sowas
nicht macht geht der greife nicht selbst
nicht eingreife so war ja die monster
sind auf jeden fall ist in echt viele
hier vor okay aber ich nehme kaum
schaden dann keine rüstung von patrick
darf jeden fall nochmal big think you
die bringen sogar nur ein halbes herz
diese natur was leistet ist ja richtig
schlimm
ok ich will irgendwie direkt hier unten
am wasser anbauen
leute ich mache schon wieder denselben
fehler wenn jetzt sterbe dann dürft ihr
mich so versuche hart verteidigen wie
ihr wollt in den comments weil was ich
hier mache die ganze zeit ist echt so
unverantwortlich irgendwie da kann er
überhaupt überall was wachsen da muss
glaube ich einen blog länder frei sein
meine ich egal wir werden dann sehen
minecraft singleplayer habe ich jetzt
auch noch nicht so unglaublich viel
gespielt dass ich das hier alles wisse
aber da ist muss auf jeden fall die
melone zu einem block hin wachsen können
so viel weiß ich schon ich alte experte
so dahin
zack zack okay da kann sie hat darin
sehen dahinter hinter hinein hier nicht
und da muss wahrscheinlich ganz normale
erde hin so und dann kann ich jetzt
endlich 2000 machen als die ganze nacht
irgendwie jetzt absätzen bei mir im haus
bzw
ich fahre jetzt noch ein paar bäumchen
und dann baue ich einfach ein bisschen
am haus weiter weil hier zum zum
nächsten zum weitermachen bei der black
magic möchte ich halt erstmal die die ja
das
doch das fliege dingen machen sagen
thema mit dem man halt fliegen kann
das sieht das ähnlich mannschaft seit
folgen von sie mir die ganzen drogentote
dazwischen gekommen so weiter sehr doof
aber irgendwann demnächst werden wir
dann auch wirklich schaffen wenn ich
ganz zuversichtlich und ich glaube wir
legen uns einmal hier die aus sicht frei
auf den auf den fluss da also es ist
jetzt nicht irgendwie finde ich von von
nachteil dass wir die landschaft hier
ein bisschen auseinander nehmen
geht das in usa ging es nicht so scharfe
vorbei drop der fleisch- und essen ist
ja bekannterweise nicht so nicht so
wirklich falsch wenn man sich bei mir
die letzten folgen angeschaut hat so und
jetzt ab nach oben da anscheinend
irgendwie ja einigermaßen cooles nacht
event
ich muss man überlege ich glaube man
kann auch mit dieser traktor wenn man
irgendwie cool platziert dann ist es
nicht so stressig immer die aufzumachen
so weit so müsste jetzt eigentlich viel
cooler sein hoch zu gehen weil dann
packe ich nicht immer so da drin und
kann aber hoch das sind die kleinen
dinge leute so sprott wird gefahren
so macht das einen richtigen packung hin
oder wie mache ich das das ist alter
habe ich gerade erschrocken dass der typ
hier hochkommt kleiner was läuft einfach
in mein haus hoch wie denn überhaupt 8
ist einfach wie im weg okay da muss ich
natürlich auch darum kümmern dass das
dass das geschlossen wird wer dieser
wolf ist auf jeden fall der usa da hier
immer der sport ja auch wirklich immer
also wirklich jede folge hätte ich die
möglichkeit unseren link zu killen oder
wie zu jagen
er ist auf jeden fall auch noch eine
sache so um apple haben wir wir können
uns sogar gold äpfel machen
für später dann blut opfern von nike
so eine schaufel wollte mir noch machen
das ein bisschen sandfarben gehen kann
dafür müsste ich wieder runter an den
see und da hab ich ja bekannterweise ein
bisschen schiss kann man daraus leiste
mache mir nicht okay kann jetzt wieder
hochkommen oder war das nur der eine
blockt den unterschied gemacht
ich glaube es war der einen blog zum
glück egal aber wir holen sich natürlich
also hand experience muss ja definitiv
auch ran geholt werden
ich glaub so normale maus bringen gar
nicht mehr mittlerweile also wenn man
park getötet hat dann ist es halt
einfach nur noch lästig diesem ops zu
töten so torarm kollege müssen auch mal
schauen dass wir das also ich weiß nicht
was da diese nacht los ist und wir
können es jetzt auch mal angucken ob die
sich dir wie sich die rüstung bewährt
hat er die nimmt schon alter schwede
heute sieht der sowieso besonders groß
aus
oder ich bilde mir das schon ein okay
leute die nächte sind echt gefährlich
also ohne patrick nochmal riesiges
dankeschön an dieser stelle werden wir
da schon ziemlich verloren einfach da
weil er uns jetzt dass das ganze zeug
gegeben hat so und ich muss jetzt so was
wir machen ist eine schande eigentlich
hier wie ich mich wie ich mich herum
umschlage jetzt würde ich halt ganz gern
ein bisschen sandfarben gehen aber
andererseits will ich ganz gerne ich
schon wieder sterben
ich bin so einem kleinen
interessenkonflikt kann man hier
irgendwo noch was mit haut mit holz
bauen
ich könnte es ja ich mach das mal ein
bisschen symmetrisch würde ich sagen so
seien 123 x 3 okay halt in die andere
seite auch noch so einem kleinen sicht
vorsprung wie ich das jetzt hier getan
habe so eigentlich lächerlich dass ich
dieses haus so verschönere weil so
besonders toll ist das irgendwie nicht
aber ich hatte ja eigentlich den plan
gab mir mein haus an
ein kran zu hängen freilich wirklich
keinen job und deshalb wäre es ein
verlust ich finde ich wenn man dann
irgendwie noch so ein kran drum herum
baut um dieses haus und das häuschen
besser gesagt das ist ja echt nur eine
kleine boot aus ist nicht schön
also ich finde minecraft kann echt schön
aussehen insbesondere in dem ort pack
also ok anders aus
das freut mich jetzt kann ich erstmal
diese nervigen piepste dinger töten und
dabei ein bisschen melone kassieren
also ich hab ihn schon stressig wenn die
alten hit landen kriegen die machen die
ich muss auch wirklich das ist noch so
wichtig das war durch das update hat
sich der chat wieder verstellt so der
chat hat sich dadurch wieder verstellt
und das war so stressig ist denn ich
konnte als ich da gestorben wird
letzterer konnte ich gar nicht sehen wie
viele herz nicht noch hatte ein schaf
allein wäre jetzt nicht so special
aber okay da könnte ich mir vielleicht
dass endlich mal ein bett bauen müsste
die nächte durch nicht immer angst haben
reaper wie viel punkte hat er nochmal 50
das heißt man könnte ihn schon schaffen
aber ich kämpfe sie hat eine lava das
muss ich mir auch bewusst sein und als
jobs verloren aber ich weiß nicht ob ich
irgendwas gejobbt haben überhaupt so
habe ich auf jeden fall richtig wenn ich
ein bisschen sollten wir holen möchte
zuckerrohr ist eigentlich nicht falsch
für bücher dann aber ich glaube das
haben wir schon angebracht okay die acht
unterwasser teppich weißen kann man
irgendwas machen bei dem unterwasser
tempel
als er dann schließlich noch mal aus
aber die folge ist auch schon wieder an
wobei nicht ganz 90 minuten ich habe ja
am anfang vor der aufnahme muss ich noch
etwas einstellen
deshalb denkt mal hat ein bisschen
kürzer gedauert aber ist in unterwasser
tempel eigentlich was tränen ich mein
ich hab im singleplayer eingefunden und
dann war der so vollkommen unspektakulär
und zweifache
nichts drin sie weiß nicht ob das jetzt
immer so ist oder ob ich da irgendwie
pech hatte
aber ich gucke mir das gleich noch ein
bisschen player an bevor ich die nächste
folge auschecken ansonsten gehen wir mal
in den wasser tempel und das ist
natürlich nicht verdienen der ist jetzt
vielleicht glauben so ein 1.9 tempel
sondern halt nun ja wort pack tempel
also es gibt ja dann auch mit den
guardian und so gibt es ja diese neuen
tab ist okay ich werd mir noch ein
bisschen kohle mitnehmen und dann bin
ich auch schon wir direkt zurück zum
haus dass wir wenigstens kohle so haben
also ich hab ja schon schon letztens mit
mit vettel festgestellt dass irgendwie
zumindest stark von mir die die basics
einfach vernachlässigt werden
also einfach so sachen die einfach es
weiß halt jeder so dass man das braucht
aber zum beispiel keiner kümmert sich so
richtig ums essen und so was und ich
könnte eigentlich mein status als
bürgermeister so ein bisschen ausnutzen
in unserem fall und einfach sagen hey
auch bringt mehr alle essen oder mach
das mal
aber ich befürchte dass meine stadt
nicht so nach meiner tante pfeifen würde
wenn ich das sage so wie ich die ganzen
rabauken kenne und deshalb ich lieber
keine unruhen oder sowas hier riskieren
für den für den fall okay leute nie los
hier
ich werde einfach mal zu sehen der alter
sehen sind so viele von diesem funke
hier
ich werde gucken was da drin ist aber
auch im klimaschutz schreiben kann
sowohl person die viecher sind so
stressig so also wir haben echt ein
kleines monster ob problem irgendwie in
der stadt aber das ist glaube ich eher
so eine max sache dass man überall
probleme
okay leute als gleichwertig auslagen das
war's von heute und bis zur nächsten
folge macht's gut